mean 36 hours now since the explosions
at the dam so it's pretty clear that
this is a very big act it's a it's a
catastrophe for Ukraine which is as bad
as in its own way the Chernobyl nuclear
disaster of 1986 and as the hours go on
we're getting more clear about what
those implications may be this was the
dam before the explosions and with maxar
satellite imagery it's in black and
white because it's been produced very
very quickly but you can see the dam
there breached in three places we hoped
yesterday that maybe the damage wasn't
as bad as it originally looked but it is
pretty bad and that that is clearly
breached so the reservoir the Kafka
Reservoir will now just flow into the
NEPA River along with at least 150 maybe
three or four hundred tons of fuel oil
which will go with it which will
contaminate the Black Sea and cause
major problems
um further on if we look Downstream
again maxar satellite imagery shows the
difference before and after keep your
eye on the residential area not the not
the water you see what's happened to the
residential area down river curse on
itself is a port and if you look at the
Deport occurs on same sort of thing you
can you can get the idea of the the
residential area but you zip a maxar
satellite image across it and there's
nothing but Devastation so you know
there's the port of cursor and you can
see uh light out like craft and barges
unloading uh put the maxar image across
it Max our satellite imagery that's the
sort of damage that it's done and even
if you take a a small village like
um krinky which is uh where there's a
tributary of the nepra river to the
north I mean look what it's done to
krinky again look at the residential
area so it's all pretty bad and getting
worse as the implications become clearer
as the hours go on so what's the
political reaction being well um just
now President Putin has said to
president erdogan of Turkey he said this
is a catastrophe he said this is a this
is a dreadful act or indeed it is Mr
Putin
um the question is who did it and at the
United Nations people are being a bit
cagey formally they're saying that we
need evidence and when we've got
evidence of course this is a war crime
which undoubtedly is and privately
nobody's got any doubt about who's done
this and a lot of other politicians even
Chancellor Schultz of Germany yesterday
he's a very cautious man but he came out
and he said this is Russia they do this
sort of thing and it's absolutely
Dreadful so I think the Russians can say
what they like nobody believes that this
is not a militarily coherent act the
Russians are getting something out of
this militarily and they've done it
without regard to the civilian
consequences that's a war crime
let's talk about the fighting on the
ground away from here what's going on at
the moment yes I mean the the
um War continues overnight there were a
lot of strikes at least 30 odd
um missiles and drones were brought down
by the ukrainians but some strikes I
think got through but another night of
air strikes down in the southwest in
Kirsten this is what we're talking about
the novakov kadam draining into the into
the Black Sea this area is now not a
good place for the ukrainians to try to
attack they might not have tried in any
case but that now will will take that
area out of contention so it Narrows the
front that the ukrainians can can work
on but elsewhere in the front there's an
upsurge of fighting right along
particularly in the in the donbass so
it's fatove criminal the Russians have
been pushing there quite recently and
maybe are pulling back a back moot uh
the uh ukrainians are pushing North and
South there's a big battle
um going on now at uh
which is just North of back mode and
that's a really big battle that's been
developing over the last few hours and
the ukrainians are pushing quite hard
and if we look at the south of the
country in general across the South you
can see what the ukrainians might be
trying to develop they're they're
exploring at the moment but the two big
strategic possibilities is one is
supposedly they drove South to Melita
Pole right down to the coast if they
could do that they would actually be
able to threaten Crimea and that would
be a huge uh uh Advantage political
Advantage if they could do that but
that's a big ask unless they difficult
to ask me to push South to mariopol that
would put them on the scene as of get
married Paul back as a port and that
would still split the Russians into two
sections those are strategically big
objectives but one suspects that that's
what the ukrainians have got in mind
something like that how they'll do it
how they'll go about it and how long it
will take we don't know but this is what
we're all looking for whatever we see in
the donbass is preliminary to something
bigger we suspect further south in the
weeks ahead yeah Michael thanks very
much indeed thank you